l'année 2020 nous souhaitons étant donné
que nous avons la chance de piloter
l'opération territoire d'industrie nous
souhaitons que de nouveaux projets et
mes hanches que nous consolidions les
entreprises existantes et que nous
puissions disons d vraiment dynamiser le
territoire avec des innovations
intéressantes dans dans toutes sortes de
domaines
ça peut être aussi bien le domaine de du
bâtiment que le domaine agroalimentaire
que le domaine également par exemple de
l'exploitation industrielle des
sargasses tout cela peut être très tout
à fait porteur d'avenir pour nous nous
avons l'habitude de nous battre donc
effectivement nous les industriels nous
sommes des nous sommes optimistes
autrement nous ne ferions pas disons ce
que ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
c'est à dire fabriqués localement malgré
tous les obstacles qui existent pour la
production locale
mais nous savons aussi garder les pieds
sur terre et pouvoir mesurer tous les ai
tous les dangers tous les impacts
défavorables qui existe dans notre
environnement économique actuel
l'octroi de mer n'est pas une
ce moment pour une loin puisque nous
simplement nos matières premières à
l'importation sont exonérés d'octroi de
mer et nous lorsque nous produisons nous
ayons de leurs droits de nerfs sur la
production locale et la production que
nous fabriquons néanmoins l'octroi de
mer à 7 10 ont cet avantage de pouvoir
compenser un peu
les surcoûts que nous subissons par
rapport à l'importation qui on le sait
bénéficient soit d'économies d'échelle
totalement disons incomparable avec nos
petites unités de fabrication ou alors
qu'ils bénéficient de salaires
autrement plus bas que les nôtres